we is it weird for you when you're a
senator and you go everyday to the
Senate and you and it's and there's not
that many senators so you get to know
them on a personal level and you're
friendly with them blah blah blah then
you announce you're gonna run for
president and they're so scummy to you
I mean nasty is it mind-blowing to you
to have to absorb that kind of betrayal
there's like a spectrum you expect some
of it you know some of the Republicans
that I served with never said a bad word
about me I've never said a bad word
about them a lot of them do the
obligatory well you know she's a
Democrat I'm a Republican so obviously I
have to say something but then there are
those who've kind of fallen off the edge
and have so changed their personality in
my view their politics like a Lindsey
Graham like a Lindsey Graham but she
blowing your mind now because he's a
completely different guy he you know I
traveled with him because he was you
know a very good buddy of John McCain
who I admired and and liked enormous Lee
so I traveled all over the world with
McCain and Lindsey and other senators
and Lindsey was good company he was
funny he was self-deprecating he also
believed in climate change back in those
days man yes well you would say I'm
concerned about the future for my
children well he doesn't have any
children but he was concerned about the
future yeah absolutely and so I saw him
as somebody who you know had been
working to try to figure out what he
believed and how he could do things as
he sold his soul to the devil I don't
know the answer to that I think that's a
fair question however and and what I
don't understand is how he went from
being the friend and and the you know
real confidant of the Maverick John
McCain who you know I didn't agree with
politically but I found him to be a man
of integrity as a man of you know real
strength of conviction the guy spent
five years as a prisoner of war
you ever been to Hanoi have you seen
that so he stayed in for five years it's
a tiger cage god it's I mean it's
unbelievable and so I admire John I
became really friendly with him I felt
like he was a true friend
and so then Lindsey all of a sudden you
know John McCain tragically dies
soon after standing up for healthcare
which was astounding and so in character
for him and now you know I don't know
what's happened to Lindsey Graham I I'll
be honest with you I haven't talked to
him in a long he wrote you know how Time
magazine has like the top 100 people all
that one year back in a couple of years
ago when I was in it he wrote the
tribute to me and then now it's like he
it's like he had a brain snatch you know